this is a chart that shows the
percentage
of the total population of each of these
colonies and then later states
that was made up by enslaved africans
starting in the year 1754
which will show in purple
and comparing that to the year 1800
which we'll show here in green now some
of these numbers are estimates
since the census didn't exist before
1790 but this can help us get an overall
sense of how the institution of slavery
changed in these years now on the left
side here we have the data from the
northern part of the country
now in purple you can see the percentage
of the population of each colony that
was enslaved in 1754 and generally it
wasn't a very large amount i think new
york here had the most at about 14
by 1800 however you can see that the
percent went down considerably
some like massachusetts outlawed slavery
altogether so they're at
zero percent and others like new york or
rhode island began a process of gradual
emancipation phasing out slavery another
thing to note is that new territories in
the west that were claimed by the united
states either had very small amounts of
slavery like in the indiana territory or
none at all like in the northwest
territory where slavery was outlawed now
let's compare that to the same period in
southern regions in most of the south in
enslaved people made up a very
significant portion of the population in
some cases like in south carolina
outnumbering whites at a rate of more
than 60 percent of the population and
unlike in the north as you see here in
teal in 1800 enslaved people remained a
really quite large percentage of the
population in some cases the percent of
people who were enslaved grew
considerably like in delaware or in
georgia and in other places stayed about
the same in places like virginia and
south carolina the percent of the
population that was enslaved actually
dropped over this time period but not
because there were fewer slaves but
rather because the white population had
grown faster than the enslaved
population in the same time period and
unlike in the northern territories the
percentage of enslaved people in the new
southern territories claimed by the
united states kentucky tennessee
mississippi
was quite significant as well so what's
happening here why over this 50-year
period did slavery begin to die out in
the north while surviving and even
expanding west in the south how much
change was there over this time period
in the regional attitudes about slavery
and how would we even go about figuring
that out
one way that we can attempt to measure
the extent of change
is by identifying the things that stayed
the same during this time period which
we call continuities
or aspects of society that
continued on being the same as they were
before and changes
aspects of society that were different
than before
there are many different aspects of
society that historians can trace
changes and continuities in over time
like changes in politics or arts or
gender roles
but for this video i'm going to choose
economics
and ideas
why am i choosing those two well first
and foremost because slavery was an
economic practice it was a source of
labor that supported the production of
agricultural products second i know that
in this time period the american
revolution introduced radical changes in
ideas about liberty and equality which
stand in stark contrast to the
institution of slavery so let's compare
the economic systems and ideas about
slavery
in each of these regions
in 1754 and 1800
to see
what changed and what stayed the same so
first let's look at the economic systems
in the north
where the climate and the soil was not
suited for large-scale plantation
agriculture the economy centered around
family farms in 1754. proximity to the
coast facilitated fishing and shipping
and the people who actually did this
work tended to be either the owners of
the farms or the boats or indentured
servants
and a small number of enslaved laborers
who worked for them none of these
activities really required the labor of
a large number of enslaved people all
right well what about in 1800 farming
and
fishing and shipping were still going
strong but as the first industrial
revolution began to take off in the late
1700s
factories began to spring up in the
north and the cheapest labor source for
these factories was immigrant laborers
not slaves not indentured servants now
let's look at the economic systems of
the south in 1754 and 1800 in 1754
plantation agriculture based on enslaved
labor was the central economic system
and it was also the central economic
system in 1800 but unlike in the north
where the technological innovations of
the industrial revolution made
indentured servants or enslaved laborers
unnecessary the major technological
innovation of the cotton gin made cotton
easier to process and therefore saved it
as a profitable crop which made slave
owners eager to expand the institution
of slavery rather than phase it out next
let's take a look at the ideas about
slavery which were commonly held in each
of the regions in 1754 in the north i
would say a few people questioned the
existence of slavery northern shipping
was involved in the atlantic slave trade
the idea that masters deserve to rule
slaves was as natural as the idea that
kings deserve to rule their subjects
even free people of color were rarely
considered full british citizens the way
people of english descent were how did
things change in 1800 the revolutionary
war had a strong effect on the ideas
about slavery in the north northerners
apply the revolutionary ideals of
liberty and equality to long-standing
ideas about social roles and they found
that slavery was incompatible with them
so after the revolution northern states
either abolished slavery or began to
phase it out with gradual emancipation
but i want to caution you into thinking
that this turned the north into a racial
utopia people of african descent were
still not permitted to become american
citizens even though the immigrants who
were beginning to flood in from europe
were so i think it would be fair to say
overall that the north had never really
needed slavery and therefore when the
revolution
led many to question the institution of
slavery it was pretty easy to abolish it
how does that compare to the south's
transition in this time period well by
the notion that slavery was natural and
enslaved africans were property was
pretty well ingrained but the ideas of
the revolution didn't have quite the
same effect on the south as they did in
the north if anything by 1800 white
southerners were determined to enact
harsher slave codes than ever because
they feared uprisings since the ideals
of the american revolution had inspired
the haitians to overthrow the french so
why do these changes and continuities
over time matter well because by 1800
you start to see attitudes around
slavery crystallizing in the united
states creating a north where slavery
was rare and considered a perversion of
the ideals of the revolution and a south
where slavery was central and considered
natural and perhaps even a desirable way
to organize society and as white
settlers
from each of these regions moved farther
and farther west into territories that
were opened up by the american victory
in the revolutionary war and by indian
removal both northerners and southerners
would export their economic systems and
their ideas about slavery into these
adjacent western lands by 1820 this
gradual process would erupt into
sectional crisis over slavery